19:40 in denmark is getting a little bit
nervous about its southern neighbor the
Third Reich there was good reason for
this since Germany had just conquered
Poland and was at war with Britain and
France Germany was importing resources
and materials from Sweden and so both
sides had an interest in controlling the
neutral nations of Denmark Norway this
would allow the site which controlled
them to determine how much of the
region's resources Germany would get
Germany thus decided to strike first
with operation visa among a plan to
conquer both Denmark and Norway in one
fell swoop Denmark had for the most part
seen German aggression coming since 1937
it had been building up its military
capability to deter aggression in 1940
the Danish army stood at about 14
thousand soldiers strong but after the
outbreak of the Second World War they
were ordered away from the border this
was to prevent Germany from using the
excuse of a border skirmish as a
justification for war such as they had
done with Poland this of course didn't
stop the German since Hitler wanted
Denmark at 3:15 in the morning on April
the 9th the Germans landing Marines
again sir - cut telephone lines about an
hour later German troops sailed into
Copenhagen and met no resistance and
about an hour after that the main German
assault into Denmark began since the
Danish troops weren't at the border they
weren't able to get optimal defensive
positions against the Germans but that
didn't stop them from fighting back the
German troops that had landed in
Copenhagen simply walked up to the army
headquarters and secured it without any
resistance having received such a
peaceful reception they moved on to the
Danish King Christian the temp and his
palace here the King's life guard gave
the Germans a slightly shootie a welcome
Hitler ordered bombers to fly over
Copenhagen but not to bomb it to remind
the Danes that Germany could flatten the
capital if it so wanted to on youtl and
the defenders resisted bravely but to be
blunt about it they weren't going to be
able to resist the bear mug for any
significant length of time not that the
soldiers had much of a chance to try
anyway the reason was the King Christian
had surrendered their mark to the
Germans at 8:34 though the orders didn't
reach some of the troops fighting Indian
land for another 15 minutes and that was
it Denmark had fallen to the German
Reich in a little under six hours one of
the quickest conquests in human history
so the Danish surrender was done so in
return for their maintaining control
over their domestic policies which
Hitler allowed the surrender which
occurred with Germany and Denmark
suffering very few casualties meant that
the Germans weren't as harsh from the
Danish as they maybe would have been in
fact the German government used the
speed of the war to argue that Denmark
wasn't being occupied but simply
being protected from britain denmark
would remain occupied until 1945 but the
story of that occupation is one from
another video I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching and a
special thanks to my patrons James
Bissonnette party boy Co Michael
Reynolds Gustav Swan
Winston Cawood Skye Chappell Adam Harvey
Gable airy and as ARCA Flash
you